[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
450 Millionen Dollar okay
Toni ja das
Geld aber keine Ahnung was willst Du
denn damit sagen
also für diese Rekordsumme wurde im Jahr
2017 das Gemälde Salvator mundi von
Leonardo da Vinci verkauft es ist damit
das teuerste Kunstwerk der Welt
eine halbe Milliarde Dollar von Gemälde
das ist schon recht stattlich
das zweit wertvollste Kunstwerk der Welt
ist shot said blue Marilyn vom
amerikanischen Künstler Andy Warhol der
Verkaufspreis dafür rund 195 Millionen
Dollar auf Platz drei folgt Pablo
Picassos für rund 179 Millionen
US-Dollar also das ist wirklich viel
okay okay ich verstehe also am
Kunstmarkt werden die Millionen gemacht
und das ist ja auch irgendwie spannend
aber wieso erzählst du mir das
eigentlich also es gibt ein Gemälde das
sind dieser Liste nicht auftaucht nicht
in den Top 3 sondern überhaupt gar nicht
und bestimmt auch niemals auftauchen
wird denn es ist unbezahlbar das wohl
berühmteste Kunstwerk der Welt so
berühmt wie das unverwechselbare Lächeln
dieser Porträtierten Frau aha die Mona
Lisa
genau und dass dieses Gemälde so
wertvoll ist das liegt an vielen Dingen
am einzigartigen Malstil davincis an den
Mysterien um die abgebildete unbekannte
und daran dass das Lächeln der Mona Lisa
für mehr als zwei Jahre verschwand
spurlos denn zu Beginn des 20
Jahrhunderts wurde da Vincis Meisterwerk
gestohlen na die Mona Lisa war auch vor
dem Diebstahl 1911 natürlich ein sehr
sehr berühmtes Gemälde einfach aus ihrer
Vorgeschichte aber durch den Diebstahl
hat sie natürlich den Status erreicht
den sie heute hatte sie ist berühmteste
Gemälde das berühmteste Kunstwerk der
Welt die Mona Lisa als unumstrittene
Königin würde im ich würde mal behaupten
zweistellige Milliarden Bereich liegen
das ist Walter Straden stellvertretender
bild-sportchefredakteur und absoluter
Kunstliebhaber und Experte mit ihm gehen
wir gemeinsam dem unglaublichen Raub der
Mona Lisa nach in unserer heutigen
Ausgabe von Tatort Deutschland mein Name
ist Mirko Kasimir ich bin Toni Haier
hallo für unseren heutigen Fall begeben
wir uns zusammen ins Jahr 1911 in die
Hauptstadt Frankreichs nach Paris die
Straßen sind voll fast 3 Millionen
Menschenleben zu Beginn des 20
Jahrhunderts bereits hier Kutschen
fahren dicht an der Sehnen lang die
Männer tragen Anzüge und Zylinder die
Frauen lange Ruben und Hütte das Korsett
ist abgeschafft es ist nicht mehr obwohl
wie die Franzosen sagen und hier mitten
im Trubel der Stadt im ersten direkt
neben derselben steht der Louvre das
größte Museum Frankreichs ehemalige
Residenz der französischen Könige der
Louvre ist ein pompöser eu-förmiger
Palast die Außenmauern sind verziert auf
den palastbögen da stehen Statuen also
wirklich so ein prachtvoller Bau und in
der Mitte da ist ein riesiger Innenhof
1911 existierte bekannte gläserne
Pyramide so wie wir sie heute
wahrscheinlich eher so von insta und Co
kennen noch nicht im Gebäude hängen
schon damals Kunstwerke aus aller Welt
Gemälde aus Italien Sammlungen aus der
antike Kunstwerke aus Ägypten und Syrien
im Salon Carree hängen die italienischen
Meister ein großer Raum der beinahe
einer Kapelle gleicht die Decke ist mit
goldenem Stuck verziert Statuen von
Göttern und kleinen Engeln schauen von
oben hinab 100 Jahre zuvor heirateten
hier sogar Napoleon und Marie-Luise von
Österreich im Jahr 1911 sind die Wände
des Salon Carre voll behandeln dicht an
dicht hängen die Schätze des Louvre
neben und übereinander und hier
mittendrin beinahe unscheinbar hängt
Leonardo da Vincis Mona Lisa schon
damals strömen Besucher reihenweise in
den Louvre um die ausgestellten Werke zu
sehen und natürlich zu bestaunen und
auch vor 100 Jahren kam manche Besucher
auf die Idee die Kunstwerke zu zerstören
oder zu beschmieren deshalb hatten
bereits viele Gemälde schon zu Beginn
des 20 Jahrhunderts so ein Schutzglas
drumherum im Oktober 1910 bekommt die
Mona Lisa ihr neues Glasgehäuse
angefertigt wird dieses unter anderem
von einem in Paris lebenden Italiener
namens Vincenzo Perugia Vincenzo ist
klein und schmal er trägt einen
Schnurrbart seine Wangenknochen sind
eingefallen seine Augen dunkel und die
Ohren spitz
drei Monate verbringt der damals
30-Jährige im Louvre für die Arbeit
trägt Vincenzo einen weißen Kittel so
wie andere Glaser oder Kopisten die sich
im Museum aufhalten im Januar 1911 ist
Mona Lisas Schutzglas fertig und
vincenzos Arbeit erledigt
eigentlich
denn mehr als ein halbes Jahr später
kehrt Vincenzo zurück in den Louvre aber
nicht als Glaser sondern als Verbrecher
der Italiener hat einen Plan er will die
Mona Lisa stehen und wie sich
herausstellen wird ist dieser Plan
einfach sehr sehr einfach denn alles was
Vincenzo dafür braucht das ist sein
weißer Kittel bis heute streiten
Historiker über den genauen Ablauf des
Diebstahls manche Experten sagen
Vincenzo Perugia hätte sich an einem
Sonntagabend in das Museum geschlichen
und sich über Nacht in einen Wandschrank
im Louvre einschließen lassen in dem
sonst Staffeleien und Leinwände gelagert
wurden am nächsten Morgen soll er sich
so die Theorie aus einem Versteck
geschlichen seinen weißen Kittel
angezogen und auf die Suche nach der
Mona Lisa begeben haben andere
Historiker sind sich sicher der Dieb ins
B sei am Montagmorgen kostümiert in
weißem Kittel in den Louvre sp ohne
wandschrankversteck fest steht an einem
Montagmorgen am 21 august 1911 da
betritt Vincenzo die Ausstellungsräume
des fluvre damals ist der erste Tag der
Woche noch ein Ruhetag außer einigen
Wachmännern Kopisten Fotografen und
putzkräften da befindet sich keiner im
Gebäude Wünschen zu schleicht sich in
den Saal Karree und steuert zielsicher
auf Leonardo da Vincis Kunstwerk zu mit
ihrem verschmitzten Lächeln schaut die
Mona Lisa dem Italiener ins Gesicht ihre
neugierigen Augen starren direkt seine
dunklen Pupillen
Vincenzo versichert sich ein letztes Mal
dass er allein ist hebt seine Hände
und nimmt Leonardo da Vincis Meisterwerk
einfach von der Wand keine weiteren
Befestigungen und keine Alarmanlage
hindern ihn daran die Mona Lisa zu
stehlen ist ein Kinderspiel
Vincenzo läuft ins Treppenhaus ganz
vorsichtig löst er hier den Rahmen von
dem Gemälde und versteckt die Mona Lisa
unter seinem weißen Kittel das Ölgemälde
hat eine Größe von 77 x 53 cm und wurde
auf Holz gemalt zusammenrollen und
beispielsweise in seinen Hosenbund
stecken das kann vincento also vergessen
deshalb Brezeln bis heute viele
Historiker wie der Dieb da Vincis
Meisterwerk erfolgreich unter seinem
Kittel verstecken konnte eines der
vielen Mysterien um diesen Diebstahl der
Italiener läuft die Treppen hinunter und
steuert auf den Nebenausgang zu sein
Fluchtweg der seinen Kuh besiegeln soll
doch die Tür klemmt der Tür Knopf ist ab
Vincenzo ist jahrhundert die Kanal droht
aufzufliegen ja bis dem Gauner der
Klempner des Louvre entgegenkommt
Vincenzo nutzt die Chance und bittet den
Hausmeister ihm die Tür zu öffnen und er
Klempner ist hilfsbereit denn auffällig
ist ein Vincenzo nämlich erstmal gar
nichts das Kopisten oder Glaser
montagmorgens das Gebäude verlassen ist
ganz normal und das unter dem weißen
Kittel Leonardo da Vincis Meisterwerk
versteckt ist kann keiner ahnen mit
einer Zange öffnet der Klempner die
Italiener die Tür
Vincenzo und die Mona Lisa verlassen den
Louvre
Werbung
sorry
Journalist und Kriegsreporter aber
Gustav die regelmäßig Folgen aus meinem
Reporter Erleben
der Podcast jeden Mittwoch eine neue
Folge ab dem 9 August überall da wo es
Podcast gibt
[Musik]
Werbung Ende
Vincenzo lebt zu der Zeit in einer
billigen Absteige vom Museum sind das so
ca 40 Minuten zu Fuß in seinem Zimmer
versteckt er da Vincis Meisterwerk in
einem weißen Koffer mit doppelten Boden
und im Louvre bleiben vier Nägel an der
Wand zurück vier Nägel an denen bis vor
kurzem noch die Mona Lisa hin
am nächsten Morgen mehr als 24 Stunden
nach dem Diebstahl betritt ein
französischer Maler den Salon Carree er
möchte eine Kopie der Mona Lisa
anfertigen als der Künstler das
lehrerwahnstück entdeckt wird der
stutzig und fragt bei einem Wachmann
nach die ist wahrscheinlich beim
Fotografieren antwortet der Aufseher und
kümmert sich nicht weiter um das
vermisste Kunstwerk das Bilder einfach
so abgehängt werden können das ist für
uns heutzutage etwas seltsam aber zu der
Zeit war das im Louvre jedoch gang und
gäbe denn der damalige Direktor des
Museums wollte das Fotografieren
bedeutender Kunstschätze fördern um
beispielsweise Verhandlungen nach einem
eventuellen Diebstahl zu erleichtern
somit konnte jeder vertragspfotograf des
Louvre Gemälde einfach von der Wand
nehmen und im Atelier fotografieren aber
als nach Stunden des Wartens die Mona
Lisa immer noch nicht zurück an der Wand
hängt wird der Maler ungeduldig und
fragt erneut beim Wachmann nach
gezwungenermaßen fragt der Aufseher beim
Louvre Fotografen nach und die Antwort
lässt ihm das Blut in den Adern
gefrieren die Mona Lisa wird und wurde
den ganzen Tag noch nicht fotografiert
das Gemälde ist weg der Louvre wird
abgesperrt mehr als 50 Polizisten
durchsuchen jeden Zentimeter des Museums
doch von dem berühmten Lächeln fehlt
jede Spur nur den Rahmen des Gemäldes
finden die Ermittler im Treppenhaus
Frankreich ist schockiert so etwas hat
es bis dahin noch nie gegeben die Presse
überschlägt sich eine Zeitung bietet
sogar eine Belohnung für den der die
Mona Lisa zurück bringt doch es passiert
gar nichts das Gemälde bleibt
verschwunden keine zwei Wochen nach dem
Diebstahl erscheint ein Artikel in einer
französischen Zeitung ein Mann namens
Baron dormison beschreibt darin wie
einfach es sei aus dem Louvre zu stehen
er selbst habe es bereits getan und
mehrere iberische Statuen völlig
unbemerkt mit gelassen und diesem
Anschluss an einen Pariser Maler
verkauft als Beweis für seine
Anschuldigungen schickt er der Zeitung
gleich eine gestohlene Louvre Statue mit
im weiteren prophezeit der vermeintliche
Baron sein diebeskollege würde die Mona
Lisa bald zurückbringen und was als
nächstes passiert das ist fast so
unglaublich wie der Diebstahl an sich
schnell stellt sich heraus dass es sich
bei dem angeblichen Baron dumme Song in
Wahrheit um einen gewissen Geri Piri
handelt ein tauge nichts und Bekannter
des französischen Schriftstellers giom
opulinar und dessen guter Freund ist
wiederum ein Bekannter Pariser Maler ein
sehr bekannter Maler den wir bereits am
Anfang der Folge erwähnten
Pablo Picasso und tatsächlich ist
Picasso im Besitz eben dieser zwei aus
dem Louvre empfohlenen Statuen und gerät
damit in den Verdächtigen Kreis der
Pariser Polizei die Ermittler gehen
davon aus dass apollinär und Picasso in
den Diebstahl der Mona Lisa verwickelt
sind der Schriftsteller kommt deshalb
sogar mehrere Tage ins Gefängnis und
Picasso muss vor Gericht aussagen unter
Tränen beteuert der Maler gegenüber dem
Richter seine Unschuld verleugnet vor
lauter Angst sogar seine Freundschaft zu
Apulien her das Gericht spricht die
beiden Männer frei Picasso muss nur die
iberischen Statuen zurückgeben die
Statin sind also zurück im Louvre doch
die Mona Lisa die bleibt verschwunden
wochenlang gehen die Ermittler jeder
Spur und jedem Hinweis nach
zwischenzeitlich werden sogar die
französischen Grenzen dicht gemacht was
keiner weiß die Mona Lisa liegt die
ganze Zeit über keine vier Kilometer von
ihrem rechtmäßigen Platz im Louvre
entfernt und zwar genau wir erinnern uns
im Koffer von Vincenzo Peru das Zimmer
Wochen Monate ja Jahre vergehen die Mona
Lisa wird aus dem Museumskatalog
gestrichen anstatt des Porträts der
unbekannten hängt jetzt ein Bild des
italienischen Künstlers Raphael an der
Wand die Hoffnung des Gemälde zurück zu
bekommen ist erloschen bis zum 29
November 1913 weit weg vom Tatort im
italienischen Florenz bekommt der
Kunsthändler alfredogerie einen Brief
Senior Gerry ich bin im Besitz des
Bildes der Mona Lisa ich möchte das
Gemälde an mein Vaterland Italien
zurückgeben zur Deckung meiner Unkosten
verlange ich 500.000 Lehrer gezeichnet
Leonardo
[Musik]
Senior Gary hat den Brief erstmal für
einen billigen Scherz doch ganz lässt er
ihn nicht los der Kunsthändler wendet
sich an den Museumsdirektor der Uffizien
also des berühmten Kunstmuseums von
Florenz der heißt Giovanni Pocci und er
rätsino Geri auf das Angebot einzugehen
die Männer vereinbaren ein Treffen mit
dem Unbekannten Leonardo die beiden
Kunstexperten verabreden sich in einem
kleinen Hotel in Florenz mit dem
unbekannten Mann zur vereinbarten
Uhrzeit tritt Ihnen ein kleiner schmaler
schnurwertiger Mann gegenüber es ist ihr
ahnt es sicher schon genau unser alter
Freund Vincenzo für das Treffen ist der
ganova aus Paris angereist und trägt in
seinem Gepäck das wohl begehrteste
Kunstwerk der Welt mit sich ahnungslos
und fast schon desinteressiert beginnen
die Männer das Gemälde zu inspizieren
noch mal weiter Strafen
empfiehlt das Bild in der Hand und was
wir vom Donner gerührt als erfahrener
Kunsthistoriker wusste er natürlich
quasi um jedes krakeli sind die kleinen
Risse die immer in alten Malschichten
sind und es gab in der oberen Seite der
Mona Lisa einen größeren riss und genau
der den kommen Fälscher so genau
Hinblick bekommen hätte der war da und
er drehte das Bild um und sah auf der
Rückseite auch die mental Nummer des
Louvre die auch nicht so bekannt war und
dann war er wie vom Donner gerührt und
hielt in einem billigen Hotelzimmer in
Florenz die geraubte Mona Lisa in der
Hand doch seniori und der offizien
direktorji lassen sich von ihrer
Aufregung nichts anmerken sie zeigen
zwar Interesse und verabreden sich für
den übernächsten Tag mit Leonardo um den
Kauf abzuwickeln insgeheim schmieden sie
aber einen anderen Plan statt die Mona
Lisa zu kaufen rufen die Kunstexperten
die Polizei beim nächsten Treffen der
drei Männer am 12 dezember 1913 wird
Vincenzo verhaftet und die Mona Lisa
sichergestellt
unmittelbar danach beginnen perugia's
Verhöre der Italiener gesteht und
behauptet allein gehandelt zu haben beim
Diebstahl ging es ihm nie um Geld
sondern um Patriotismus denn Vincenzo
war der Auffassung da Vincis Meisterwerk
hänge unrechtmäßig im Louvre und gehöre
eigentlich nach Italien mit dem
Diebstahl wollte er die Mona Lisa zurück
ins Heimatland davincis bringen
also das Thema Raubkunst beschäftigt uns
ja auch heute immer wieder also wem
gehört die Kunst die vor allem hier in
Europa in Museen ausgestellt ist oder
sogar Stadtbilder prägt grundsätzlich
ist es ja ein ehrenhafter Gedanke von
Vincenzo
man muss nur leider sagen die Geschichte
der Mona Lisa hatte Italiener da leider
ein bisschen durcheinander gebracht denn
so unrechtmäßig hängt sie nämlich gar
nicht im Louvre Walter strapen erklärt
uns jetzt mal wieso ja man muss klar
sagen die Mona Lisa ist keine Raubkunst
sondern legal erworben worden vom
französischen König Franz den ersten der
hatte Leonardo in seinen letzten
Lebensjahren sozusagen in Hamburg Oasis
Quartier gegeben und nachdem Leonardo
gestorben war hat er dieses Bild seinen
Schüler und Geliebten soweit bekannt ist
salaii vererbt und der wiederum hat das
Bild in an den französischen König
verkauft und so ist es denn über die
königliche Sammlung gekommen ein
italienisches Gericht verurteilt
Vincenzo Perugia zu sieben Monaten Haft
bevor die Mona Lisa zurück in den Louvre
kommt wird sie in mehreren italienischen
Städten ausgestellt im Januar 1914 fast
zweieinhalb Jahren nach dem Diebstahl
kommt da Vincis Meisterwerk zurück nach
mit großangelegten Fototerminen
zelebrieren die Ermittler und
Angestellten des Louvre Mona Lisas
Rückkehr ähnlich euphorisch läuft Monate
später vincenzos Gefängnis Entlassung ab
vor dem Gebäude wartet eine
Menschenmenge auf ihn sie jubeln ihm zu
er ist zum italienischen Nationalhelden
geworden fast zwölf Jahre nach seinem
Diebstahl am 8 oktober 1925 da stirbt
Vincenzo es ist zeitgleich auch sein 44
Geburtstag man könnte meinen die
Geschichte des Raubs der Mona Lisa sei
damit auserzählt doch genauso mysteriös
wie ihr Lächeln ist auch ihr Diebstahl
denn bis heute 25 viele Experten daran
dass Vincenzo allein gehandelt haben
soll zwei Theorien halten sich bis heute
hartnäckig fast zehn Jahre nach
vincenzos Tod erscheint ein
Zeitungsartikel in diesem berichtet ein
amerikanischer Journalist von einem
Treffen mit einem argentinischen
Hochstapler namens Eduardo defalfiano
dieser soll gegenüber dem Reporter
behauptet haben habe Vincenzo mit dem
Diebstahl beauftragt
fallsiano hätte bereits im Jahr 1910
also ein Jahr vor dem Diebstahl sechs
Fälschungen der Mona Lisa anfertigen
lassen und plante diese an reiche
Amerikaner jeweils als vermeintliches
Original zu verkaufen damit falls
janusplan aufging musste dafür natürlich
zwischenzeitlich die echte Mona Lisa
verschwinden
und so kam Vincenzo Perugia ins Spiel
die Geschichte aus dem Artikel hat sich
jedoch nie bestätigt und es ist
eigentlich ziemlich sicher dass in den
letzten 110 Jahren irgendwo irgendwann
eine dieser Fälschungen aufgetaucht wäre
somit ist diese Geschichte vermutlich
eher eine Legende oder der Versuch eines
Mannes sich selbst zur Legende zu machen
eine andere Theorie aber die führt
tatsächlich hierher also zu uns nach
Deutschland ein letztes Mal Walter
Strafen es gab in Paris zu der damaligen
Zeit ein ursprünglichen Kölner namens
Otto Rosenberg der soll Perugia im
Louvre bei dessen Arbeit als Glaser
mehrfach angesprochen haben und
sozusagen heiß gemacht haben die Mona
Lisa zu stehen mit der Argument dass er
ja ein italienisches Kunstwerk und es
gehöre zurück nach Italien die Franzosen
vermuteten weil es ja auch schon vor dem
Ersten Weltkrieg politische Spannung gab
das ist ein deutscher Agent Provokateur
war der sozusagen den Raub der Mona Lisa
Provo hätte um Frankreich zu schädigen
Tatsache ist dieser Rosenberg hatte
Kontakte weniger in die deutsche
kaiserregierung als zu einer belgischen
kunsthäler und Diebes Bande und
möglicherweise hat Rosenberg tatsächlich
eine gewisse Rolle gespielt
Vincenzo Perugia anzuheizen aber dafür
gibt es natürlich nach mehr als 100
Jahren auch keine Belege mehr sicher ist
jedenfalls 1 dass die Mona Lisa heute
noch mal gestohlen wird ist beinahe
unmöglich heute hängt Leonardo da Vincis
Gemälde allein an einer Wand hinter
Schuss sicherem Glas der Bereich davor
ist abgesperrt museumswerter beobachten
das Meisterwerk permanent und jeden Tag
strömen bis zu 30.000 Menschen durch die
Hallen des Luftraum die meisten von
ihnen um die Mona Lisa endlich ein
einziges Mal mit eigenen Augen zu sehen
ja das Erlebnis ist heute jedenfalls ein
ganz anderes als noch vor 100 Jahren die
Menschen stehen heute dicht gedrängt vor
da Vincis Meisterwerk
Gott allein mit der Mona Lisa ist man
eigentlich nie das war zuletzt wohl nur
dem Dieb Vincenzo Perugia vergönnt und
das war unsere heutige Folge von Tatort
Deutschland wir haben mit Quellen der
Frankfurter Rundschau New York Times
weltwirtschaftswoche und des
Deutschlandfunks gearbeitet es gibt
Lilly von der Osten Redaktion Stefan
netzebart Postproduktion wie immer durch
die Wake world Studios München wir hören
uns beim nächsten Mal gibt uns gerne
Bescheid wie ihr diese Folge fandet
gerne per Mail oder Instagram die Links
wie immer in den Shownotes danke dass
ihr mal wieder mit dabei wart macht's
gut eure Tony und eure Wirkung ciao